flanked by his wife Dominique
strauss-kahn arrived at court to a
hostile reception a crowd of hospitality
workers gathered in support of his
alleged victim inside the former IMF
chief pleaded not guilty to charges of
the attempted rape and sexual assault of
a 32 year old chambermaid
any more salmon so yes after the hearing
strauss-kahn's defense team took the
opportunity to speak on his behalf the
only thing we will say is something we
said during the first appearance in this
case and our judgment once the evidence
is reviewed it will be clear that there
was no element of forcible compulsion in
this case whatsoever lawyers
representing the maid who will take the
stand to give evidence said this was
about more than just their clients she's
standing up for all women and children
around the world who have been sexually
assaulted or sexually abused
and are too afraid to say something this
case now moves to the pre-trial phase to
allow both sides to go away prepare
their arguments and decide what kind of
evidence might be admissible in court
they're due to meet again here in six
weeks time Dominique strauss-kahn left
Court quickly returning with his wife to
his rented home in Manhattan's up
markets Rebecca area they're under
24-hour armed guard the former French
presidential hopeful awaits his day in
court Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News New
York